they know that if they dare step up and
fight the monster well the monster will
come for that just broadly on Jordan the
best thing that I can say about Jordan
so we did about a hundred and ten stops
in a year it was incredible we went to
dozens of countries truly the best thing
that I can say about Jordan is he is the
real deal
I have never met someone in this space
that the exact man that you guys know
that you watch these videos of is the
exact guy the second economists go off I
never saw him be rude to anyone anywhere
I mean try to imagine the amount of
people that would come up to us
everywhere airports bathrooms
restaurants all the time it's a minute
before a show he's running late stop ask
them how they're doing what you know
what their name is and and the other
thing and this is probably more
important I never saw him break one of
the twelve rules
he had many opportunities that he could
have lied to somebody about oh I can't
talk cuz I gotta go or whatever he never
broke one of the twelve rules as a
matter of fact there was one night some
of you guys may have seen the picture we
were in London and Jordan and I and
Majid namazi probably no had dinner at
Douglass's Mowgli's Murray's flat that's
that's apartment in London EADS and we
had dinner there and you know one of the
rules is it the 12th rule may be the
11th rule about petting a cat if you see
one on the street and it really what
he's saying there is you know don't
forget to stop and smell the roses so
Douglas had a cat and we're in there for
about three hours we're eating we're
drinking we're having a great time and I
noticed about 3-4 hours in and I had a
plenty of drinks I was like I don't
think Jordan has pet this cat and I was
like if he doesn't pet this cat the
guy's a fraud like
and I could and then you know like then
and then we're like five hours in I'm
really drunk and I'm like Skyy gonna pet
I couldn't stop thinking about it like
if he doesn't pet this cat like I'm on
tour with the biggest fraud in the
history of the world anyway
we're saying our goodbyes Jordan gets on
the ground now Jordans really tall and
like he gets on the ground and sits with
the cat basically sitting in the cat's
bed you know just like little flatbed
and just try I mean you can picture it
because you can sort of picture Jordans
hands and just petting petting petting
the cat and I thought all right the gig
goes on we're gonna be okay yeah he said
he's a great guy and he's the real deal
and and and he's serious about his ideas
and and and I'm a better person for
having done the tour truly yeah good for
you yeah the thing that fascinates me I
see this a lot when people have opinions
it's very easy to what I should say it's
difficult to state an opinion that you
know is gonna be against the grain yeah
and you know that I wouldn't say it's
controversial but you know is you know
the person saying it feels it or knows
it as fact believes it is fact and then
they kind of stop and I think that's
just one other note I want to make in
that interview where it's like you know
he would say something and stop and it's
just so not accepted in society to say
some of the things he would say without
like but you know this this and this or
you know I believe this that's an
opinion I mean he just would say it well
the irony of course was that every time
the media would try to sandbag him and
try to destroy him which we saw many
times you guys may remember that one at
one of the biggest moments was when the
New York Times wrote that piece that
Jordan is for enforced monogamy remember
that and everyone made it sound like he
wants to basically put make women slaves
and we're gonna be in the hands made
tail enforcement ugly just means
marriage it's but you if you look
actually Eric Weinstein checked out on
the New York Times archives the only
other two references to enforce monogamy
are positive references about marriage
that marriage is a fundamental building
block for a Western society it's it
causes us to reproduce and have familial
bonds and all of these things but the
more they attacked him by him just
keeping his cool and this is this is a
good lesson for any of you guys if
you're ever gonna be brave enough to say
anything you
believe in the more they attacked him
the more he stood his ground and he
would say he would say you know by
nature I'm not a combative person and
that's hard to believe when you see
these people they're in these fights
constantly but he would stand his ground
say what he believes and say simple
truths
I'm not against trans people but the
government can't tell me what to call
somebody I'm for marriage I mean you
know basic stuff and if you do that and
you don't lose your cool
well everyone he's a worldwide
phenomenon and those things go hand in
hand yeah so I want to go back to you
know we talked free speech kind of as a
broad ten but I want to talk you know
specifically a lot of the students in
the room and kind of this campus culture
of free speech you know you see a lot of
comedians that won't go to campus just
because of some of the backlash and the
current environment that's been created
so one of the things that I really think
is missing
amongst the libertarian and conservative
crowd is this idea that we continue to
say campuses biased campus shuts down
our speakers they don't recognize our
student organizations they don't let us
get rooms you know to actually have have
speakers or meetings but then we don't
do anything about it and about three
almost four years ago now you know we
launched a program called the national
fight for free speech campaign with the
idea of saying let's stop just
complaining let's figure out what are
these bureaucrats and the college
administrators doing to shut down our
groups or to shut down speakers and you
know you have certain campuses need to
get a permission slip to go out and do
activism and talk to people a lot of
them will charge the outrageous security
fees that's really curse at the campus
and I love how you say that it's the new
one because what happens is and these
are typically you know liberal campus
bureaucrats somebody try is a new code
or a new policy and it works and then
all of a sudden you see other people
picking it up well we used to when we're
trying to combat them we will try to
purposefully do an event that is against
the code so let's say they have these
free speech zones right they say okay
listen it's a public school we're
supposed to uphold the First Amendment
but just to protect everyone we have a
small zone
size of let's say an iPhone on a tennis
court right if that's the campus and
this is where you're able to speak
freely well we will purposefully do an
event outside of it and it's funny we
used to do a free speech wall the
university said it's a fire hazard
right I mean they they're very smart
knightly smart these administrators so
then we to push back now we do free
speech beach balls these giant beach
balls are roll around campus but we do
these events but it's crazy to me that
college administrators will shut down
not controversial opinion I mean they do
that and I don't I don't believe they
should be doing that but we have
students who have handed out pocket
constitutions they've gotten arrested
and put in jail the document literally
has the First Amendment written in it so
what do you think his what do you think
has caused this authoritarian belief and
and do you really think it's that
administrators want to protect students
now is it more of a control thing no
it's it's neither it's actually it goes
back to the core of what I talked about
are the factory settings before and it
goes back to what has happened with the
modern left that has that in academia
more than anywhere else I mean this is
where this whole horrible set of ideas
of post-modernism took root and all of
these people know the administrators and
the faculty know if they'd except with a
few exceptions University of Chicago is
pretty good on it and there's a couple
other schools that are that are fighting
for free speech but they know as an
administrator that if they dare stand up
and defend then Shapiro's ability to
come to a school or the I mean look the
idea that Shapiro whatever you guys
disagree with him about is fine the idea
that he's a controversial speaker is
completely bananas the Shapiro probably
I would guess agrees with you know
policies of Ronald Reagan probably 99%
now you may not like some of those
policies that's fine
but the point is that it was mainstream
conservative thought only you know 25 30
years ago something like that but they
know that if they dare step up and fight
the monster well the monster will come
for them so that also goes back to why I
know that
we'll eventually be eaten by this thing
it it's a constant movement of
destruction it's not about creation
there was a video I'm sure some of you
guys saw this I spoke at the University
of New Hampshire it has a couple million
views and before the event right before
the end about an hour before they said
we can't secure a room on campus
apparently I'm so controversial that
they could not secure a room now so they
had to take it off site so we had a
condo maybe 400 students there or so and
and it was sold out for the size of that
room we had it was 400 people in a 400
person room there were more people that
wanted to get in they couldn't get in
but then they said we can't secure the
room so they moved us to the local
hockey rink which sat 10,000 people so I
spoke for 400 people in a 10,000 seat
arena which is extremely bizarre but I
don't bring that up because I'm talking
about the numbers as much as they
already said we lost if a university
says we cannot even secure our own
campus they have already lost and then
you know the protesters come in and you
know they they scream that I'm not for a
free speech or I'm a bigot and a not
seeing the rest of it one of the girls
kept calling me a homophobe which my
husband has no idea you know it's like
and you know the best part of that one
and if you haven't seen this it's on
YouTube just just search Dave Rubin New
Hampshire saying there's there was a
woman in the back screaming at me that I
hate trans people she kept saying I hate
trans people so I said I just want to be
very clear about my feelings towards
trans people I want them to be treated
with the exact same dignity and respect
and the exact same laws that under the
same laws that everyone else has to be I
said specifically to her I made sure to
look at her I said I hope that you have
someone that you love in your life and
you found happiness and all of these
things and then she called me Hitler in
a Nazi and all that bla bla bla but the
best part of this I did not know this
until weeks later it turns out that she
was a gender studies professor at the
University I mean really when you think
about how deeply corrupt so you'll but
you have a faculty member of a really
made up you know it's not it's not a
it's not a real set of ideas right it's
not but it could have just it could have
just as easily been an economics
professor or whatever else the idea that
they are literally they're shouting down
speakers and you know I'm not I don't
want you guys to mob her anyone else
watching this the mob but it doesn't
even matter it would be nice I suppose
if the students of the school did
something but that she felt empowered
enough because of her place in the
intersectional scale that she knew she
could go to an event scream down to a
speaker try to silence a speaker and and
know that she'd have complete impunity
and no matter what I said I mean that's
the other thing I offered her every
piece of goodness that I had to say I
don't know what our differences are
exactly but I certainly don't hate you
and I don't I don't hate I currently
don't hate anyone because of their
identity but but that's the weird state
that that we're in and and I suppose
that it'll probably keep getting worse
because I don't know if you know this
but we're in an election year and we
hate we ain't seen nothing yet if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlists all right
over here and to get notified of all
future videos be sure to subscribe and
click the
Bell